Je suis ici avec Jake Shailene Woodley
qui joue noisette la presse de coupe de cheveux
est les gros seins si vous regardez
le fan euh il n'y a pas une photo où
ses cheveux sont plus longs que ses épaules
il y a aussi elle a besoin de ressembler à une
sorte d'ici typique du Midwest
dix-sept  ans et nous sommes allés sur scène
jusqu'à ce que nous pensions tous que
Hazel était vraiment pleinement représenté, c'était quand vous êtes
Hazel, je pense que cela pourrait être tout à fait comme
Hazel, c'est bizarre en fait de vous voir
faire cette transformation parce que vous êtes
différent d'elle à certains égards.  re
très similaire à bien des égards quand tu
vas être elle c'est tellement bizarre pour moi alors
tu es comme elle dans mon esprit tes mains
sont si cool eh bien elles ne sont pas si
froides que juste sous-oxygénées j'adore
quand  tu me parles de médecine car je fais
partie de ce film était vraiment l'un des
plus beaux cadeaux de toute mon existence